tja die politik hat versagt aber wir
möchten unsere pflegekräfte feiern
unsere leser können pfleger oder
schwester nominieren und da haben wir
einen schon gesehen das ist nämlich der
herr wachtmeister einer der nominierten
die von patienten vorgeschlagen werden
können und für alle wind insgesamt
25.000 euro wird bild an pflegekräfte
insgesamt zahlen die die halt gewinnen
wenn sie ausgewählt werden und wie
gesagt wir haben ein wachtmeister schon
gesehen ist pfleger wir würden gerne
wieder bei uns haben ja
hallo
sagen sie mache ihren job was machen sie
genau ja ich bin in der
intensivmedizinischen
das was sie gesehen haben war die
intensivmedizinische krankenhaus und ich
aber den patienten direkt zu hause am
bild die ebenfalls waffen sind nicht nur
nicht so schwer wie sie es gesehen haben
aber ist arbeitet zu hause und bin zwei
stunden nur für den patienten und
versorgen medizinischen klinik
zwölf stunden lang bei einem patienten
das ist natürlich eine sehr intensives
modell finden sie das besser als das hin
und her auf üblichen pflegestation
absolut in der stellenbeschreibung oder
eine
firma auch ein kind jedoch klar
definiert zulegen wie man sie mal
gelernt hat und ich werde ich intensiv
kümmern und in dem fall und in allen
anderen fällen der familie so dass man
in diese familie in einem text und mit
dem alltag zusammen interagiert
irgendwann eine einheit ist und dieses
bild pflege nicht liegen lassen gar
nicht mehr so ins gewicht fällt was ist
wird zum alltag und das machst du die
patienten unfassbar leicht wieder neuen
lebensmut zu befinden und wieder in
lebens- und dann finden sich auch
gesundheits verläuft sehr sehr positiv
herr wachtmeister jetzt wurden sie ja
diniert dafür unseren bild pflege bonus
zu erhalten wer hat sie denn da
überhaupt nominiert ja vor allem an der
sehr geerdet überrascht da nicht sagen
dass das ganze nicht einmal eine
teamleistung und als interviewer zwölf
andere kollegen kollegen hinter die
nachricht übernehmen die andere
schichten sein leben und das müssen wir
ein team das sich abwechseln und ich war
ja häufig nominiert weil ich das oft bin
und wir viel gemeinsam zusammen
integriert und erlebt haben und zwar
ganz anschreiben kannst du geistig von
schaut es dann mal an herr wachtmeister
wir schauen mal was er gesagt hat
hallo liebes bild team ich wollte mich
drüber melden ihr kennt mich ja ich bin
der stefan und ich pflege seit
vielen jahren schon meine mutter und
meine frau jetzt eine frau journalist
erkrankt und
sie muss dem krankenhaus und dann musste
sie eine brachiale bekommen und seitdem
benötigt sie auch intensive pflege und
wir haben das große glück gehabt dass
wir ein pflege team gefunden haben von
assistenz und die sind einfach super
besonders ans herz gewachsen ist meine
frau pfleger rené der wirklich liebevoll
und aufmerksam sich um sie kümmert und
ihr auch wirklich neuen lebensmut
geschenkt hat
ja aus diesem grunde nominiert pfleger
rené für den pflege bonus der bild denn
rené wachtmeister
weil das hat er verdient hat vielen dank
das sind doch schöne worte herr
wachtmeister sie sind ganz gerührt
beschreiben sie doch mal die arbeit mit
frau walter wie intensiv ist das
ja wieder in den alltag integriert ist
gar nicht auch dass intensives man sieht
dass sie ein appartment ist die muss ich
doch mal alle halbe stunde stunden
abgesagt werden man muss ja auch ihre
kommunikation und mich achten ihre
jüngste erkennen und weil sie kann sich
ja der weißen äußern sie jetzt ein
sprachführer ich weiß nicht was auch die
bildchen und ich schreibe also wörter
und wird in sprache umgewandelt und
jetzt habe ich das gut noch mitteilen
das war so unfassbar
leichthin was möchtest du jetzt liegt
sie richtig geht's nicht gut
müssen sie um positioniert werden aber
dass man zwei stunden am patienten es
ist schon wahr nicht unwichtig und
das intensive
absagen darauf achten dass die vitale
und ja gemein zustand für alle
beteiligten herr wachtmeister sie machen
ganz tollen job vielen dank und wir
drücken die daumen dass sie den bild
pflege bonus gewinnen sie werden von uns
dankeschön dankeschön